the House GOP has just voted to defund  the IRS specifically they voted  unanimously to repeal the Democrats Army  of 87 000 IRS agents the very first Act  of the new Congress says Kevin McCarthy  because government should work for you  not against you promises made Promises  Kept now the establishment GOP can  justify a vote like this on its usual  grounds which is that we just want to  cut taxes the only thing that  Republicans ever seem to agree on is  that we just want to cut taxes but this  is about more than that it's about  cutting the agents it's about shrinking  the agency  it's about stopping Joe Biden's massive  increase to one of the executive  agencies that has been used since at  least the Obama Administration to  persecute conservatives this is really  not about taxes I'm all for a tax cut  please cut my taxes that sounds great  but it's really not about that what this  is really about is how power is wielded  in the country